hmm I was bored in school lots of us
were and when kids are bored and
restless schools usually blame the kid
one in five high school boys diagnosed
with ADHD millions are given drugs to
try to make them sit still
I was the rowdy kid that was the bad kid
and so they really really pressured my
parents to actually put me on ADHD
medication edirol yeah adderall ritalin
it was like I had been lobotomized
and my parents said this is not our son
they then sent him to other schools he
hated them all I would come home I would
sometimes just cry what better things
could have been doing during that time
when I was a sitting in a classroom
having information chucked at me so what
did you do I left he left because he
heard about a school the teachers in a
different way the school is the Academy
of thought and Industry but the school
costs money I got a job at a coffee shop
to work here he got up at 3 in the
morning by 3:30 he was in the shop
setting up tables and chairs cleaning
the counters I wouldn't get the bacon
frying get all those all the breakfast
items ready hard work just to go to this
school Academy of thought and Industry
it sounds Soviet I want my students to
think with their minds and understand
the world I don't want them to get stuff
done Michael strong started the Academy
telling parents kids learn better by
doing actual work teens need
responsibilities Ben Franklin Andrew
Carnegie Thomas Edison started their
careers at the age of 12 or 13 yeah that
was abusive child labor I worked as a
teen I loved it at his schools there are
now 2 with more on the way students get
Friday's off to work on their own
projects there are no lectures instead
students read and discuss things because
there's still people and people still
certain drives that's very different
from schools strong attended and hated
school is 13 years of how to be passive
and how be how to be independent
the republican-controlled House of
Representatives sit still
read listen to your elders repeat anyone
know the effects school is about aim aim
aim aim aim and never get stuff done so
I want students who let's just go out
there and get stuff done fail get up try
again that's how we become creators
entrepreneurs we want them to do what
they love now Cade was given projects
like start a business today why was that
more interesting than studying history
or doing science prize cuz the money cuz
the money I'm currently working on
making a web-based chat application
students study what they care about I
want to be a programmer I love
programming we got to create a project
and immediately start you know feeling
the rewards of it I was doing a few
sketches for like the costume designs I
actually work at a paintball place if
they love paintball then they should do
a business in that Dorian domi started a
music business at this point in my
career had booked almost 200 bands his
music festival brings in tens of
thousands of dollars we have students
who have done websites for American Idol
finalists these people used the website
that is their own for about nine months
and then he fired the team and a high
school team and gotta read her to him
that was great experience for my
students to get fired by a client is
actually a really good experience you do
that several times and that's how you
get better at getting stuff done so
companies hire strong students Cade got
a marketing job right out of high school
at a place called la spear which I
currently own that today people say you
got to go to college well look at me
most of strong students do go to college
we've had students be admitted to top
liberal arts colleges Bard Bennington of
course they do weld you're charging that
tuition only rich kids can afford to go
there and they're going to do well the
kind of kids that we get come from all
walks of life we had a student from New
Jersey he was incapable of functioning
in the highly structured public school
system in middle school elementary
school as you know incredibly socially
isolated in the public schools he needed
a
full-time aide he was costing the state
an enormous amount of money he came to
our school he did not need an aide
coming here is just healing it's
incredible so much so that some students
wake up at 3:00 in the morning to go to
work to help pay tuition it was me
choosing my life